how's it going bros and Rosie's
monning's being it back and look at my
loading screen it's awesome it has the
fun oh it has Scullion didn't bro and
all these kind of stuff if you want this
as well you leave the download link in
the description and the name who got her
this guy who made it for me it's really
cool that he made that for me ok but and
I don't know why I'm wearing my mom's if
that's awkward
we're gonna play ball those discovery in
this story you play us ball though I'm
not with bracelet okay that sounds fair
I lost the save file for unexpected
arrival I and I have really missed the
day today so I don't have time to like
go back and play through everything side
when I know you guys want a video
something to do what the [ __ ] what what
the [ __ ] look [ __ ] was only that
yeah man with penis today wow they're
fully surfing ha ha Nick teleported
naked guys
no mom teleported naked guys
oh man I'm so screwed I'm so freakin
screwed teleporting naq guys oh my god
oh my god oh my god
pick up the freaking tinderbox Jesus
penis okay oh man I'm so screwed [ __ ] I
have a knife though I'm [ __ ] prepared
let's get this guy right off his ass
okay thank you let's not do that okay
wish I had my lantern it's still dark
another tinderbox maybe we can move the
bed and we'll find secrets secrets are
usually under debate it's so dark
where's the closet look at my closet my
closet me yeah
Stefan oh hello pity how you been
I looked everywhere for y'all actually I
was just hanging out he always you
always hang out on barrels Johanna
what's up with that yeah I don't know
I'm golden it is just a fun I like to be
on good spots so yeah we got to go in
here oh we have to leave stuff on the
right away also excited oh wait
alright I already have the key though
I'm sorry every week Stefano it's fun of
her old ways always find him like on a
barrel or actually not he's just there
somehow randomly okay forget we're good
oh I don't trust you not good at ah I'm
just staying here and you need to get
out I don't even know how I am it's
untrusted it didn't solve by itself
oh my mind is so blown right now no put
it back I don't trust you put it back
oh my god someone did someone make this
for me I don't know I just got a message
in the side page you should try this and
then I downloaded it kind of started
think it was made for me
oh yeah we got lighting a table out of
my um oh what is that oh [ __ ] I spilled
my drink
I give hitting my leg get my [ __ ]
like ah I do this why'd I get done that
look I spill my [ __ ] drink are you
happy now
are you happy oh my god [ __ ]
teleporter naked guys my mom warned me I
should have listened so I can teleport
Aniki eyes man oh man
it's locked and I need a key I don't
even know if I want to keep it I got
this the [ __ ] jump scares in this
game holy [ __ ]
okay just take a chill pill okay
I'm not relaxed I'm some relaxed right
it's broken I can't go back so I walk
through them I walk through the whole
frenzy okay now we're good
can't go in there oh yeah I picked up
the crowbar
I forgot I can use it there maybe the
other door that's yeah there we go
now that was it oh man
oh man look at this room look at these
piano it's beautiful
man we're pretty close to fire though
now that'd be food and everything right
it for me [ __ ] I'm not ready for a
naked guys Scully
I love it welcome to dinner
Dell will be putting this look at my
cousin okay uh we have a needle know I
gotta leave Scully there because I don't
really like Scully that much okay she'll
pill she'll freakin pill
why are we going so dark I can't see ah
[ __ ] statues man I'm walking in
circles oh yeah here we go I'm doing
this the needle it's so dark I don't
trust this at all it's way too dark just
by itself
man that's sexy Tori you can check moles
read by Larry me I didn't know that
Wow it's pretty cool
okay so what's up with this room there's
something in it oh stop oh my leg ah ah
ah okay new plan new plan I'm gonna sit
like this teleporting naked guys it's
worse
holy [ __ ] is sexy though oh man I can't
do this
stop it just stop teleporting you
literally came out of the closet but
don't
[ __ ] I don't know okay then we go in
this room okay here
ha ha ha what what what
the ski ski ski
that's Susan it's always my right leg
that I just got huh what's that what's
up with this frickin castle I'm
apparently a man with great and her life
yeah
here's a phone
teleporting lanterns [ __ ] great
supper this place
oh wow I win here Oh
manly man
let's go here first on
maybe this is why we want to go like in
the end or something yeah pretty much
we need to exit this [ __ ] castle
that's for sure
blue lights everywhere oh man didn't
sound very good someone is [ __ ] up
over this place that's for sure I don't
trust you
Wow this [ __ ] customer let's go right
left first check all the doors as usual
why not
just saying
the [ __ ] was that
Kenickie there I don't have a key so
yeah that went well let's go left my god
stop doing that at least I didn't hit my
[ __ ] leg what's the point of that
this [ __ ] scared me
oh I'm glad looks like why they keep
doing this gig nigo it's pretty sweet
neo brah I want one of those mice edges
in my statutes really
what okay let's take it easier ah
Oh [ __ ] television today was that
flying visas again got his penis is like
nothing okay so
can we go in there yeah we can Oh
barrels it's gonna pick this up don't
[ __ ] with me barrels don't [ __ ] with me
forever eight barrels
the fans freaking much okay and can we
go down here no but I have a keen off
and so I think we gotta go to the other
place where we need the key
[ __ ] this [ __ ] mod
Oh freaking frack alright so I'm gonna
end it here thumbs up the video add four
to favorites
we'll go here tomorrow I really don't
have more time today sorry I'm a [ __ ]
walking paradox no I'm not threesomes
with a [ __ ] Triceratops Reptar
rapping as I'm marking deaf rock stars
wearing synthetic wigs made of n wash